months after a Tennessee woman's
disappearance nobody reported her
missing not even her husband but Marsha
Brantley's hairdresser leave it to the
hairdresser became suspicious and tipped
off police after she missed a regular
appointment her husband claimed that
brently walked out on him but she left
nearly everything behind behind brother
here's a preview of Peter Van Sant's
report for 48 hours
in 2009 Marsha Brantley an aspiring
novelist and animal lover vanished in
Cleveland Tennessee nine years later her
husband Donnie was about to stand trial
for murder a case it sounds like a 48
hours mystery a Bradley County woman
disappears without a trace I knew that
something was very very wrong
Kelly delude was Marcia's hairdresser
when Marcia missed an appointment in
2009 Kelly started calling around and
eventually called police one of the
strangest things about this case is that
four months nobody had reported Marcia
Bradley missing not her family friends
or even her husband we have a guy who's
told numerous lies about where his wife
went Bradley County detectives Zach pike
says Donnie claimed Marsha left him but
it was striking how much she left behind
even her beloved dogs in this 2013 civil
deposition Donnie didn't want to talk
much about his feelings for Marsha when
did she stop being the love of your life
new charging you with first-degree
murder
Donnie Brantley was first arrested in
2013 prosecutors dropped the charges
after deciding they didn't yet have
enough for a winning case never dealer
percentages in 2016
District Attorney General Steve Crump
recharged Donnie Brantley using
essentially the same evidence he
murdered her he murdered her what proof
is there that she's in fact dead to
convict Donnie Brantley of murder
his attorney Lee Davis says the state
first has to prove there even was a
murder Davis says Marsha had emailed
friends suggesting she might go missing
and that she was isolated and depressed
she's a smart woman who left her reasons
of her own
Kelly delude wants a jury to decide if
he did do something to her and if I just
let this go he'll get away with it at
the last minute a stunning development I
have some rather startling news to tell
you Peter Van Zant joins us at the table
good morning first I'll order the
hairdresser because she knows women
don't miss her appointments without
calling I'm also a little suspicious
because she may leave the husband but
she ain't leaving her dogs behind that's
right that was a big part of this she
had three dogs dogs and she left she's
not leaving the dogs he's not leaving
the dogs and that's part of the
circumstantial case that this
hairdresser who's a very special person
in this hour
she actually cut the hair of a local
attorney told him about the case he goes
to the DA's office and said you need to
start looking for what I think is a dead
woman in this town and that's how it got
going was from me what happens that they
hear a dresser so other than the fact
that the husband didn't report her
missing which is also suspicious is
there any other evidence against him he
told about five different stories about
where she had gone he said that she had
taken her cell phone with her but in
fact the cell phone pinged at the house
and he used that very phone within a day
or two after she disappeared to call a
dating website used a phone he used
colorful a dating website how quickly
somewhere right thank you Peter but
there is a very dramatic ending to this
which I'll have to let you watch to see
that's called a very end that's a tease
you can see Peters full report it's
calling missing Marcia that's tomorrow
night it airs at 10:00 9:00 central
right here on CBS